irgendjemand hätte mir keinen hat so
eine frisur ich komme doch nicht so
fröhlich nikolaustag also gestern für
euch heute für uns und wir können heute
unser nicolas tierchen aufmachen fragst
du dich so wie man sich um 7 uhr morgens
freuen kann ich hab schon geduscht und
war gleich nach köln aber vorher machen
wir noch unser türchen auf willkommen zu
blockte gloggnitz tagwerk knüpfen oder
lieben lasse die 6a war schnell gefunden
er tauschte das öko aus und ersetzte es
mit milka schokolade schublade lange
leitung gerade haben wir so die worte
natürlich kommen würde wäre das echt was
euch in drei stunden auch ich habe sie
gebraucht gemacht dass es weiter nach
hinten geleitet weil er glaubte schnell
gezogen habe ich schon dahin versteckt
dass falls sie mal so die jede schublade
auf machst du mir sofort schießt gibt's
diesmal auch schöne so eingepackt hat
was drauf steht
leute wurden des tages life is for
living gläubiger schreibt solche dior so
ich ihm ein geschenk machen
oh mein gott ich muss los ich kann es
nicht mehr vor die auf machen
ich muss 90 kam polly aufmachen
obwohl schnell schnell ich kann ich
würde nicht so schnell
das extrem lange gebraucht dass meine
expectation übertroffen
wie lange man schublade so lange
gebraucht
zwei minuten gebraucht
schokolade das ist eine schokolade aus
geil ich dachte meine rätsel sind solo
das ist hier halt überhaupt keinen spaß
machen aber an scheiß diese schon hat er
hatte schon ein bisschen geschauspielert
[Musik]
ich bin kein anwalt
traust du dich nicht ist dazu hole oder
soll ich jetzt zu den hier
ok
guck mal freddy knuddeln grundwert du
nicht da bist ja alle sind nicht da ich
bin alleine ich komm nach köln und
keiner begrüßt mich außerdem der ist da
und ich muss noch ein sexistischen
aufmachen ich hab es mitgenommen und ich
habe vergessen meinen ganzen an
natürlichen mitzunehmen ich bin so dass
nikolaus frühwein
der nikolaus ist wieder da wo ich bin
mit drei rohren
ich bin seit drei stunden in frieden
ruhen weil wisst ihr wer sich endlich
mal getraut hat das haben wir schon mal
gedreht
ich komme wieder hier rein wie gerade
eben als wir das schon mal gedreht haben
hallo
na jetzt sage ich den satz von gerade
eben ich sehe nicht aus wie in einem
normalen youtube zeigt da habe ich ein
tor lag hallo jetzt mit steve steve
ready
wir haben den wir haben den look klar
also geht raus
das ist für den kranken zu muss das hier
super puma das ist die neue sony ist
keine operation
ja genau diese ader 500 wahrscheinlich
rx 107
naja und dann ist das hier noch so ein
gebilde gimbel womit nicht auf touren
runter ach du kannst du mit damit
lexmark ich da nicht wahrhaben
die aufnahme beenden
[Musik]
mit erdgas war weibchen ein solches
video drehen wollte
ich bin schon seit drei vier stunden
köln und ist einfach nicht dass solche
beruflich auf ein jahr das kunstwerk
elli aber die machen dann dachte ich
noch ich hätte mal so besser mit 2
ja das wäre schön gewissens und 3d
gewesen wäre dann hätte man das so mit
schichten sondern werden die haare so
rausgekommen
man muss aber auch sagen du bist halt
einfach eine künstlerin mittlerweile ja
dass du das mal auch in deinem lebzeiten
sagen ja ich war jetzt geschnitten
videos hochgeladen
und jetzt können wir um machen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
nach instagram und erfolgt auf jeden
fall ecoline von kobe und dann habt ihr
eine chance diese tombola zu gewinnen
mal gespannt es ist magie pur wieder
gerade ist ja schön ich dies hier hab
ich heute die unangenehme person sein
die lok während der party oder das ist
eine frau aber was hast du gemacht hast
du auch gott ich dachte du hast du
gestern viel getrunken
kennedy war das sind bei der 1live krone
ja ich bin das a promi bist du also ich
find ja mag es war ganz toll ja also
schon seit ich 15 minuten bestehen
eigentlich auch geredet das natürlich
nicht passt aber den block gesehen
natürlich habe ich das zwölfte joplin
ich habe jeden zu sehen
man weiß ja was sich jetzt erwartet
so wir drehen jetzt ein porno
ich war heute aufgewacht markt in einem
hotelbett und war überzeugt dass ich
nichts zu nikolaus bekommen und war voll
sein dass ich nicht immer so stief würde
so ein weihnachtsmann hatte und fand ich
richtig
das ist keine gekommen wo der gute fällt
sie goldene von links wir kommen immer
zwei okay aber ich dachte die welt stehe
ja jetzt machen erfolgt eigentlich dass
diese leicht ist mich hat die größte
nämlich jetzt geschockt
halb voll große held die fahrten
plätzchen sind diese aber später sind
die dann auch nicht so tief weißt du wie
zum beispiel umfragen palette bis wäre
ewig diesen zwar kleiner und effektiver
das kann sein aber das wird echt groß da
aber noch geeigneter was ist dass die
heftigste schmidtgal
aber das ist also das ist ein weihnachts
und nikolaus geschenk muss ich nicht
dafür bezahlen also entweder durch sagt
das ist ein geschenk zu nikolaus ist
nicht schenken dann haben wir jetzt
schon mal hinter uns und du bist ein
pressure mir auch was zu schenken
die pässe benutzt die china und die
entstehung
es gibt jeden tag nach der benutzung
ihrer vermissten hund doch das wird was
wir sehen wie gestern wie gay games war
dass wir bei einem wunderbaren ja das
sagt das war's ich gehe das war nicht
als lösung schaffe einen berührungspunkt
offen dass sie einen berührungspunkt
einfach ein objekt das ziemlich oft
berührt funktion erhielt eine brille
schule oder in kritik jedes mal wenn ich
hier das unbewusst halte deine abkühlt
tätigkeit in deiner umgebung war kein
weißen aufgefallen ist das muss ich auch
du wirst in diesen speed videos wodurch
dem konzept ohne vermisstenfall oft die
haare es so oft noch so oft auch so
[Musik]
das sechs minuten tagebuch oder bin ich
aber geschäft bereits um 6 uhr am tag
von lange guck mal das ist der
unterschied zwischen dir und mir ich
hatte ein einsatztagebuch einsatz war
okay bis hin zum vier tage
hintereinander ausgefüllt und danach
wissen wir wo er sich ja gut wir sehen
uns dann wahrscheinlich wenn wir uns für
die party fertig machen ja wir sind
jetzt bei kelly zu hause ich habe schon
mittagsschlaf wieder zum mittagsschlaf
ich schlafe nämlich immer so abends das
ist auch der vorabend schlaf so bevor
man richtig vom haupt doch sie sind vor
der feier geht alltag
na ja und wir hatten halt hunger und das
haben wir schon mal bei freddy bestellt
empfehlung an alle neuen filme also hier
haben wir total iss gebracht hat mich in
tomatensoße pizzabrötchen steffi grafs
pommes und tatar falten also hast du das
video gesehen wo dieser typ somit nur so
ein paar falten also der das drauf
gelegt und so richtig viel mut gemacht
dass diese maske ja das war richtig
sauer das ist das nicht ein bisschen
hörte es nicht schaffen nähe vor allem
dieser oberlippen partei aber war es
dann auch alles so hier so
alles war eine gehört alles war alle
renata war auch ein gutes gesicht dazu
die oft diese weil diese nervöse ich
vielleicht hat er einfach ein größeres
gewicht als wir das können worauf freust
du dich heute am meisten aber hofft dass
wir jemanden kennen also ich freu mich
am meisten auf sascha ich frage mal ins
mikro ich hoffe gemachten foto minimiert
ich freue mich am meisten
das schöne zeit haben an ihrem
geburtstag verein und ich freue mich am
meisten auf
[Musik]
du bist ja schon hier ja da kann ich
mich ja nicht mehr druck achso am morgen
gehen wir zur linkspartei habe ich eine
bin ich + 1 der rekord kannst nicht
mitkommen
aber ich habe doch schon mal das
sozialgericht eingetragen auf der liste
weil ich jetzt mache ich gegen musik die
in dieser woche noch hier will
irgendwann so weit so klotzsche hier
ich wollte sagen in der woche nicht noch
hier bin möchte ich einmal die schminken
ich will dich einmal ein vanessa
verbauen und wenn der eine braune
perücke hat bestimmt malki ich will dich
und vanessa das wäre so cool wenn ich
müsste dann klamotten völlig aus um die
wie ich tragen würde bestimmt meine
suchen
[Gelächter]
diese größe ist knoblauch dollar
wenn der fall immer wenn es neue kapitel
der großteil finden sich längst wieder
auf eine grüne pest ist eine so dichte
und lacht
es ist recht im haus der rück sieht auch
hört sich so eigentlich aus es sollte
ein gesicht aus als hättest sowie glatze
und nur das macht sie lust irgendjemand
den weg er hat so eine frisur ich komme
dass mein ganzes gesicht endgültig mit
breitem grinsen die motive weiß
vielleicht hat
[Gelächter]
die jahr 2001
also wir machen jetzt platz bei den
blutigen muss man immer so zeitlupe
machten mit ihren looks ja mach das mal
fest gefallen da
[Musik]
ja
siehst du dich für deine zuschauer wo
ich werde die kamera nicht mitnehmen zur
party ich hab gedacht ich will feiern
ich will das leben leben und morgen früh
wieder in diesem blog schneiden
deswegen sagen wir wir müssen auch
zusammen so wilder machen kommen
[Musik]
was man nicht alles tun für den local
car style bis morgen ich bin eine woche
dabei ich hoffe ihr vorbei sagt wir
wären echt coole sachen machen jeder
wird strecke werden mindestens einen
großen kader haben
ich sehe es schon kommen hoffentlich
morgen und uns die daumen denn die
skater tipps okay beim gute nacht
klatschen uns als sie nicht schlafen
geht viel spaß